intersection in the central valley still
shut down more than eight hours after a
deadly crash we can tell you one person
was killed after as many as seven cars
crashed near torrey pines in washington
madison kimbrough hearing from neighbors
tonight she's live at what is still an
active scene
as you can see police tape is still up
and the road is still blocked off as you
can see one person died as a result of
the crash and neighbors tell me that
with all the cars involved they are
surprised there weren't more fatalities
i always hear just
people just driving by so so fast that
sometimes i'm worried that they're just
going to crash right into the the house
to my left or to the gate right here a
hectic day for those that live near
torrey pines drive in washington avenue
as six to seven cars crashed into each
other early tuesday afternoon as a
result of the crash one person was taken
to umc trauma where they later died
residents in the area say getting home
was a struggle but unfortunately they
aren't surprised by the outcome i took
several detours took me forever in the
15 years i've been here just in this
stretch there's been about i've seen
about 10 accidents this wall over here
was taken out twice within six months
they repaired it after we repaired it
yeah it was taken out again and while
it's still unknown if speed was a factor
in the crash brown says he thinks they
need to beef up patrol in the area as
people tend to drive 40 to 50 miles per
hour in a 25 mile per hour zone his
neighbor jennifer branch new to the area
and mother of three agrees that's all
you hear through here is the car is just
speeding past it's going past
really fast it's scary because i got
kids and it's like when you're driving
in this when you're driving you just be
like hopefully
no one smashes into you that's my fear
currently torrey pines and washington
are still closed but they should be
reopening within the next hour or so
reporting live madison kimbrough live
local now